now in a sickening letter sent out
across the country April 3rd has been
dubbed punish a Muslim day a letter
rates various stages of attack on
Muslims including 25 points for pulling
off a woman's headscarf 500 points for
murdering a Muslim and 1,000 points for
bombing a mosque suspect packages with
unidentified liquids have also been sent
to four Muslim MPs at Westminster for
over 10 years I've argued that legal but
inflammatory language by Muslim
extremists creates an atmosphere in
which jihadist terrorists can recruit so
similarly language that Stokes up
anti-muslim sentiment will create an
atmosphere that breeds anti-muslim
violence assuming this letter turns out
genuine and I say that with a big caveat
I urge sections of the media and anti
slum campaigners to pause and deeply
ponder their use of language I'm making
no suggestion they had any involvement
in the letter directly but all of us
have a responsibility to challenge
extremist rhetoric you can advocate
against religion without inciting
against its believers just as you can
say smoking is bad without saying saying
you hate all smokers people should be
free to scrutinize Islam but they must
not aid the hatred of Muslims imagine
there's no argument around this table
that those leaflets who are vile and
disgusting and and should not be
happiness should not be allowed to
circulate in this country but what I
what I hear at the back of what you're
saying there this is this is you this is
about free speech it's about what people
say and how they say it and and and I
guess you could say that free it's free
speech depends upon the ability to
criticize to ridicule to to just dispute
with and and we have to be able to do
that even if it's in a way that you
don't necessarily agree I mean I and I
think you're you know you probably we've
talked before and you talk talk to me
about newspapers and their language they
use when they're covering stories that
involve Muslims but but I I just I
wanted to read you something that at the
despicable Anjem Choudary said after the
Charlie Hebdo massacre
and he was saying that that no Muslims
may not agree with the I said they don't
agree with the idea of freedom of
expression even non-muslims who espouse
and save comes with responsibilities he
said in an increasingly unstable and
insecure world the potential
consequences of insulting the messenger
Mohammed are known to Muslims and
non-muslims alike now that last sentence
seems to say to me that they were warned
they had it coming and so every time we
tell people not to say things in a
certain way not not to say things that
we disagree with we're giving credence
to Chowdhury and and his belief that you
know don't say things that I don't like
because there would be consequences and
I think in this nation we live in I mean
you know you're talking presumably about
the free speech and newspapers and I'm
sure there are probably one or two
particularly newspapers you don't like
the way they they they would cover a
story that involved a Muslim but but I
still think we can't in the same free
speech its prosecutors because there are
limits on what you are you can say in a
in a democracy where there is free
speech and there's also protection
against hate speech so I think my
interpretation of what Majid is saying
is that some of the rhetoric in the
press has transgressed from not really
you took bait into inciting hate against
Muslim give us an example I'll give
examples yeah so I own a name names for
obvious reasons but we know that of late
there have been some very prominent
campaigners some of whom have been
accused by their own political party but
if they were to come to prominence it
would be like Nazis taking over their
own political party because of their
views on Muslims likewise other
prominent campaigners you know some of
them have been my colleagues have said
things like use words like the final
solution when referring to Muslims what
I'm urging everybody to do yeah Jews I'm
not saying we ban ya speech that we
don't like what I'm saying is there is a
an area between illegal speech which is
directly inciting violence and what we
expand acceptable within civil society
that gray area is usually when we
challenge bigoted speech even if it's
legal
so if a Muslim extremist came on this
show and said I want to kill gays in the
future Caliphate we would all challenge
them even though they are perfectly but
you would accept us believe in the
public arena within their legal rights
to say that because they're talking
about a future law they want in a state
but we'd still nevertheless challenge
them we wouldn't tolerate that speech
and I'm arguing
likewise if somebody's an anti Islam
campaigner uses words such as final
solution to deal with Muslims after a
terror attack that speech needs to be
challenged and it's not yet has no place
in civilized you're right you're in but
you know what I find astonishing in the
in the the you're talking about right
wing here if you look at the left-wing
arena you know in our very own Labor
Party we have people in that party
saying the most hideous things about
Jews and yet it goes it doesn't go
unchallenged but it actually largely
goes unpunished preaching to the choir
is about this is what about rehear I'm
not sure why you're sidestepping majid
you said something interesting you said
you called on all media organizations
I'm gonna quote there was a pause you
say is there a danger in some instances
that by reporting these stories actually
you are bringing them to a wider
audience who aren't aware of it and
these vile specimens say wow how do I
sign up is that something new is that
what you were driving that there is that
danger that shouldn't stop us reporting
on it not at all and that's why I use
the example of smoking is bad not all
smokers of like okay we've got to be
able to report about it in a responsible
way in a new sense that's not happening
well you know with the examples I gave
it certainly not there are certain
prominent campaigners who speak in
inflammatory ways and also of course
tabloid newspapers certain tabloid
newspapers have inflammatory ways of
dealing with still words like
cockroaches referring to extreme banned
speech I'm saying just as we wouldn't
want Islamist running around saying
extremist things up without being
challenged I'm saying we should also
challenge some rhetoric that's coming
from anti Muslim I think this I think
you're you know we've got to look at you
know Carol's point as you know free
speech but but we have to see the
consequences of not checking if not
having a pause because the rise in hate
crime religious and religious and race
crime has gone up by what something like
30 percent since last year or two
percent just over you know that is a
real indictment of the war of the tone
of society at the moment the tone of
discourse and the fact that you know we
are seeing such polarization but also a
sense of a licensing of some of the
xenophobia that had there's been an
outbreak okay but there was and what is
behind the I think it's ironic that
we're having this debate at the end of
this show because today we've talked
about Muslim grooming gangs and we've
also talked about people mainly from
Muslim communities because it's
Pakistani Bangladeshi women who a
particular identified by Louise Casey is
not speaking English now all of those
stories are completely valid and areas I
think we've all agreed deserve attention
but they feed into because of the
underlying prejudice in the society a
sense of Islamophobia and if you go to
needy L values I have you don't hear
there is a minority of people in the
Muslim community that's abuse and girls
you hear Muslim pedo zorf a street
language and we have and there's not
eleven I don't know if I am committed to
free speech but I also acknowledge that
free speech is not equally free because
there are some groups who have
disproportionate platform and others who
don't have a platform at all and that is
my worry that's why the Muslim community
coming out and challenging the
stereotypes not many Muslim editors are
there of newspapers columnist and
newspapers TV anchors people on chat
shows the reality is Chinese people
problem there aren't enough Muslims
challenging things like the grooming
gangs at the same time we've got this
problem which is why it's actually a
good thing we're debating it on the same
show because it shows this there's a
triple threat we're facing whether it's
a far-left extremist the far-right
extremists all the theocrats and we
shouldn't look if we were going to worry
about the consequences of topics we pick
that we may as well say nothing actually
you know we've got to be able to discuss
things at russia we discuss russia
it may well incite war World War three
we have to talk about right